[Applaus]
alarm im ärmelkanal
hier spricht die msc napoli 26 mann an
bord sind in höchster seenot
wenn der maschinenraum abläuft ist das
schiff verloren
ich fing auszuflippen
ich habe nicht geglaubt dass jemand
retten kannst
die wellen waren gigantisch und dazu der
schreckliche sturm ich dachte ich
schaffe es niemals bis zum rettungsboot
wie kann ein topmoderner frachter
einfach auseinander brechen was passiert
äußerst selten ich hatte so etwas noch
nie gesehen er mit oder gehen der sache
auf den grund für fehler ist kein platz
damit sich so eine katastrophe nicht
wiederholt
[Musik]
ein stürmischer wintertag im ärmelkanal
der frachter ms c napoli ist unterwegs
in richtung westen an bord mehr als 2300
container mit waren aller art von
videorekorder bis zu auto ersatzteilen
den status report bitte
valentin velev hat das kommando wir sind
auf kurs kapitän hier die wetterdaten
der erfahrene seemann ist seit fünf
jahren kapitän der napoli
das ist ein riesiges schiff um von einem
ende zum anderen zu laufen braucht man
bestimmt zehn minuten
an diesem tag macht ihm das wetter
probleme die vorboten des sturms kyrill
haben diese aufgewühlt
januar nordatlantik willkommen kadetten
das wetter macht mir nichts aus
fox darf sie muss als stecker dennoch
die komplizierten abläufe auf der brücke
lernen
ich glaube dir
wenn man versucht er die routine an bord
reinzukommen und passt sich den leuten
der stammcrew an
sie zeigen einem wo es langgeht und
deswegen muss man immer gut aufpassen
was sie tun
dinapoli ist auf dem weg vom belgischen
antwerpen nach
backbord
220 grad
220 grad backbord
[Musik]
lf ist im verzug es könnte schwierig
werden die zeit aufzuholen
[Musik]
mit 275 metern ist die napoli so lang
wie zweieinhalb fußballfeldern
die neun meter hohen wellen mit hoher
geschwindigkeit zu durchpflügen könnte
schiff und ladung gefährden
ken potter ist sicherheitsberater für
die schifffahrt und hat jahrzehnte auf
see verbracht er weiß wie heikel die
lage ist
wenn der wind von der seite kommt fängt
das schiff an zu rollen und weil durch
die container viel gewicht oben auf dem
schiff liegt wollte stärker und tiefer
[Musik]
der kapitän muss die geschwindigkeit
drosseln um schiff und ladung zu
schützen maschinenraum hier spricht der
kapitän
sich runterfahren verstanden
nach duffys schicht ende wird das rollen
und stampfen des schiffes stärke der
junger kadett versucht trotzdem zu
schlafen
man hat schon gemerkt dass draußen ein
ganz schönes unwetter war aber das
schiff wollte recht leicht wir konnten
also gut schlafen
am nächsten morgen schaukelt es heftig
der sturm hat sich zu einem orkan
entwickelt
wenn die wellen direkt von vorne kommen
ist das jedes mal wie ein schlag mit dem
hammer man knallt voll aufs wasser
[Musik]
gegen 10 uhr früh hörte ich einen lauten
knall
verdammt
wasser im maschinenraum sofort runter
und nachschauen was los ist
ein ruhe der wasserpumpe ist geborsten
wenn es der kuh nicht gelingt den
wassereinbruch zu stoppen könnten die
motoren ausfallen und die nab wie würde
hilflos auf dem meer treiben
wenn man in so einem unwetter die
kontrolle über das schiff verliert kann
es quer schlagen und anfangen zu kentern
dass sie bekommt in seiner kajüte nur
mit dass draußen immer noch der sturm
tot
ich war wie jeden morgen dabei mich für
meinen wachdienst auf der brücke fertig
zu machen
als er unter der dusche stand sind die
bewegung des schiffs völlig außer
kontrolle zu geraten
ich wurde herumgeschleudert und in
meinem kopf schrillten die alarmglocken
ein riesenschiff wie das hier
sollte sich nicht so bewegen
[Musik]
im maschinenraum versucht der
schiffsingenieur verzweifelt das pumpen
ventil zu schließen
mit erfolg aber hier geht es nicht mehr
um das rohr ein riesiger schwall mehr
wasser strömt in den maschinenraum
da denkt man als erstes wahrscheinlich
wie kann das bloß passieren
[Musik]
wir haben ein massives problem hier
unten der maschine norden wird geflutet
wir müssen die maschinen starten
verstanden
wenn der maschinenraum abläuft ist das
schiff verloren
der schlimmste albtraum jedes kapitäns
traden holz weiß genau wie gefährlich
die lage ist er war früher selbst
kapitän des containerschiffs
antrieb ist man dem mehr ausgeliefert
und das will man bei sturm auf keinen
fall sein
innerhalb weniger minuten gerieten die
schiffsbewegungen völlig außer kontrolle
ich dachte okay schnell in meiner
arbeitsklamotten springen und ab auf die
brücke ein kostelic
im gang liegen überall säcke mit den
überlebens anzügen die die männer
anziehen wenn sie das schiff aufgeben
müssen und die säcke sind leer
als ich das sah war ich geschockt
der ganze gang war mit diesen säcken
übersät
so ein anblick ist auf keinem schiff der
weltnummer
[Musik]
holt so viele wasserflaschen aus der
proviant kabine wie erkannt
als ich die anderen sah wusste ich
sofort das ist keine übung da zieht man
nicht seinen überlebensanzug an
die kadetten magath holt die anderen
schnell los los
hier aufzuhören der erste offizier
starrte mich mit riesen augen an und
rief die kadenz oh mein gott hole deine
freunde grundlage friend to friend
caffier rastlos um die anderen zu retten
ich hätte an die tür von nix kabine
du musst auch machen
wir müssen zur brücke was ist los wenn
ich das
dinapoli treibt manövrierunfähig und
leckgeschlagen auf see 80 kilometer vom
land entfernt der kapitän hat keine wahl
mehr ersetzt einen notruf ab
hier spricht die msi napoli wir gehen
jetzt zu den rettungsbooten
dass ich dachte das kann doch nicht wahr
sein dieses chef ist doch riesig wie
kann sowas passieren die crew befindet
sich in höchster seenot
der leitende ingenieur zeigte dem jungen
kadetten das problem im schiffsrumpf
kraft ein großes senkrechtes flecken
man konnte ein riesiges loch sehen ich
fing innerlich an auszuflippen
mir schossen alle möglichen gefühle
durch den kopf
wenn ein schiff auseinanderbricht kennt
hat eine seite oder beide der kapitän
muss seine leute also schnell vom schiff
bringen bevor das passiert
sobald der kapitän den befehl gegeben
hatte machten sich alle wie
ferngesteuert auf zum rettungsboot
ein schiff aufzugeben ist nie einfach
aber bei diesen wetterbedingungen war es
besonders hart
ich konnte nicht glauben was da
passierte
die 26 crew mitglieder müssen sich ins
rettungsboot zwängen das kapsel ähnliche
gebilde wird sie in tosende meer am
leben halten aber es wird kein
spaziergang
[Musik]
kurz vor dem offenen meer ist die
nächste rettungsstation fast 100
kilometer entfernt der britische marine
flugplatz carlos in südengland
dort hat der rettungstaucher jay und
donner seinen stützpunkt
ich war an dem tag der einzige taucher
im dienst und beunruhigt weil es im
funkverkehr schon hinweise
ab zum rettungshubschrauber
26 leute sind am wasser pro donnellan
schnell wie schwierig der einsatz bei
diesem sturm sein wird
ich konnte nicht fassen was da für ein
unwetter druck dort geht es wurde immer
schlimmer ich hatte das meer noch nie so
aufgewühlt gesehen
hier spricht kapitän welle von msc
napoli wir haben das schiff verlassen
und sind in einem rettungsboot auf dem
ärmelkanal verstanden
darin wurde man herumgewirbelt wie in
einer waschmaschine
weil alles total abgedichtet ist wird es
ziemlich schnell heiß wie in einer sauna
denn nicht noch schlimmer
in einem rettungsboot zu stecken mit so
vielen menschen auf so engem raum ist
vielleicht eine der schrecklichsten
erfahrungen die man machen kann man kann
davon ausgehen dass fast jeder an bord
seekrank wird
hier spricht kapitän welle von der msc
napoli hören sie mich
es gab ein tragbares funkgerät an bord
und wir versuchten darüber kontakt zu
bekommen aber aus irgendeinem grund
funktionierte es nicht ich fing an zu
zweifeln ob uns jemand retten kann
aber dann hörten wir etwas ganz in der
ferne
es klang wie ein hubschrauber
[Musik]
der such und rettungsdienste marine hat
das boot entdeckt zum aufatmen ist es
aber noch viel zu früh
der sieger und die strömung waren
gigantisch und dazu der schreckliche
sturm mit konstant 130 kilometer pro
stunde ich dachte ich schaffe es niemals
bis zum rettungsboot
es wurde hin und her geschleudert
fest an eine rettungsleine angegurtet
wird o'donnell aus dem helikopter
abgeseilt unter ihm tanzt das boot auf
bis zu zwölf meter hohen wellen auf und
ab
irgendwann war ich im wasser und schwamm
auf das boot zu ich dachte jetzt muss er
mir alleine geben damit ich reinkomme
und im nächsten moment ruderte ich mit
den armen in der luft
die männer im rettungsboot können nur
warten und hoffen
wir waren daher nicht nur fünf minuten
drin sondern ungefähr drei stunden
und die fühlten sich an wie wochen
[Musik]
endlich erreicht und donner des
rettungsboots im tobenden sturm mal
amüsiert über die schmale woods könnte
zur gruppe er glaubt dass dahinter eine
französische crew sitzt
wahrscheinlich hatte man ihm erzählt
dass er in französischer frachter
ball drin war es furchtbar sie waren
seekrank und wollten nichts wie raus aus
ihrer not man konnte die angst in ihren
augen sehen ich denke sie glaubten nicht
an ihre rettung
er hat schnell kapiert dass wir alle
englisch sprechen und er versprach und
wir kriegen euch alle hier sicher raus
muss die männer so schnell wie möglich
in sicherheit bringen der helikopter hat
nur begrenzt sprit
komm her die zeit läuft ich habe mich
angeguckt ich habe ihnen kurz die
wichtigsten sicherheitshinweise erklärt
arme und hände auf die knie
dann habe ich ihm den rettungs gut
angelegt und kurz nach oben gelegt um zu
fragen seid ihr bereit
es war so eng ich konnte mich gerade mal
so hin knien und einen nach dem anderen
raus holen
o'donnell wohl die schiffbrüchigen
nacheinander aus dem boot und hat sie
ans rettungsseil
einer nach dem anderen werden sie nach
oben gezogen
okay der richter
es musste schnell und sicher sein
an die leine los
[Musik]
ich konnte nicht glauben was ich von
meinen augen abspielte
gleichzeitig war ich so erleichtert ich
werde gerettet gleich bin ich im
hubschrauber und in sicherheit
das war einfach phänomenal
und der nächste los
nach 90 bangen minuten sind endlich alle
in sicherheit
grad da fühlt man sich wie im
glücksrausch
wir haben's geschafft
was für eine hammer leistung kraftstoff
uns aus so einer katastrophe zu retten
ich hätte nie geglaubt dass menschen für
andere so ihr leben aufs spiel setzen
die ganze crew ist in sicherheit aber
die napoli nicht das schiff treibt
unkontrolliert am westlichen rand des
ärmelkanals durch das leck im rumpf
dringt weiter wasser
experten fürchten eine umweltkatastrophe
sie warnen vor einer tickenden zeitbombe
das schiff hatte 4000 kubikmeter
schweröl an bord das ist kein normales
öl sondern zieht er war ein furchtbares
zeug
robin middleton war als staatssekretär
der britischen regierung für maritime
angelegenheiten damals zuständig für die
bergung er muss mensch und umwelt vor
der katastrophe schützen
als die napoli verunglückte stand ich
kurz vor der pensionierung mit sowas
hatte ich nicht mehr gerechnet
middleton weiß was auf dem spiel steht
rund fünf jahre zuvor sind bei der
havarie eines öltankers am atlantik
zehntausende tonnen öl ins meer
geflossen
beim untergang der prestige wurde die
spanische küste verseucht das öl der
napoli hätte die strände großbritanniens
getroffen
um eine ölpest zu verhindern wollen die
einsatzkräfte das havarierte schiff in
einen sicheren bereich schleppen dort
soll das gefahrgut abgepumpt und
entsorgt werden aber ist die
leckgeschlagene napoli stabil genug für
so ein heikles manöver
die gefahr ist groß dass sie auseinander
bricht
doch sollte sich die statik expert mal
anschauen
ein team aus internationalen
bergungsspezialisten wird
zusammengerufen
wir hatten kaum mehr als ein foto es sah
aus wie ein lecker an seitlichen rumpf
der schiffbauingenieur christ als
berater dabei
und anhand dieses fotos mussten wir
entscheiden ob ein abschlussversuch
sicher genug war
wenn das schiff im tiefen wasser
versinkt könnten die umweltfolgen noch
verheerender sein
es scheint klüger das schiff
abzuschleppen
aber wohin
wir brauchten einen ort wo man es
schützen konnte in der nähe der küste
oder eines hafens
middleton muss starke strömungen im
ärmelkanal berücksichtigen die britische
küste erscheint ihm sicherer als der weg
nach frankreich ein paar orte in
südengland könnten passen
[Musik]
beim versuch sie in diesem sturm aufs
offene meer zu ziehen wäre sie
höchstwahrscheinlich
auseinandergebrochen
er muss eine schwere entscheidung
treffen und den luxus sich zeit zu
nehmen hat er nicht
es geht nach portland zeigen sie mir die
route dorthin
middleton hat sich entschieden
ein ehemaliger marine stützpunkt liegt
geschützt an der englischen südküste
während die bergungsarbeiten laufen
versuchen andere mitarbeiter der
britischen regierung zu klären wie das
unglück passieren konnte tony brown ist
oberinspektor der behörde zur
untersuchung von see unfällen
die evakuierung lief noch und wir
wussten nicht was das eigentliche
problem an bord war
unser erster schritt war so viele
hinweise wie möglich zusammen
dinapoli ist leckgeschlagen
aber warum
danke dass sie gekommen sind bitte
setzen sie sich wie kann ich helfen
während die napoli in richtung küste
geschleppt wird versuchen die ermittler
informationen aus erster hand zu
bekommen was möchten sie wissen von der
crew die das unglück überlebt hat sagen
sie uns bitte was passiert ist nun ja es
gab einen alarm wassereinbruch im
maschinenraum
erinnerungen verblassen schnell
augenzeugen sollten immer möglichst
schnell befragt werden
das rohr war geborsten einfach so ok der
schiffsingenieur hat mit eigenen augen
gesehen wie das unglück seinen lauf nahm
und enthüllt ein interessantes detail
und dann war da dieser wand aus öligem
wasser
das meerwasser ist mit öl vermischt
diese wasserwand die der ingenieur
beschrieb gab uns einen wichtigen
hinweis
so konnten wir uns gut ausmalen was
passiert sein musste
schauen sie
hier ist das leck
öl im wasser bedeutet der schaden liegt
unter dem maschinenraum
ein entscheidender hinweis die ermittler
wissen jetzt dass das leck am
stahlskelett des schiffes sitzt
eigentlich die robusteste stelle der
kiel verläuft über die gesamte
unterseite des schiffes er dient als
basis für die trägerstruktur des rumpfes
ein riss an tragenden elementen ist sehr
ungewöhnlich
bei containerschiffen kommt es nur
äußerst selten zu so schweren schäden an
der trägerstruktur
das bedeutet wir müssen extreme kräfte
am werk gewesen sein die ermittler
fragen sich ob der sturm kyrill das
wirklich alleine geschafft hat
[Musik]
zum unglückszeitpunkt herrschte
windstärke 11 auf dem ärmelkanal
einzelne böen hatten bereits orkanstärke
die wellen waren bis zu neun meter hoch
das ist ziemlich schwere see absolut
ungemütlich aber
die ermittler interessieren sich nicht
nur für das wetter
ich bin in der dusche fast umgefallen
ach was als ob ich in der waschmaschine
wäre
der bericht eines besatzungsmitglieds
ließ uns aufhorchen er erzählte er habe
schwierigkeiten gehabt in der dusche zu
stehen vor dem riss hatte es offenbar
ein paar heftige wellen schläge gegeben
das gab uns grund zur sorge wenn das
schiff mit dem buch voran in die wellen
geht kann es zum sogenannten scamming
kommen
beim skimming überträgt sich die wucht
des aufschlags vom bug aus auf das ganze
schiff
die erschütterungen kann man überall auf
dem schiff spüren
und sie belasten den rumpf des schiffes
enorm aber
der kapitän ist ein erfahrener seemann
maschinenraum hier spricht der kapitän
maschinen 371 reduzieren
verstanden
er passt die geschwindigkeit an und
denkt sein schiff sei sicher
es ist wie bei den bränden auf der
straße wenn man damit fast 70 sachen
drüber geht ist das auto kaputt der
kapitän gibt es wegen dem befehl
langsamer fahren
sie hatten wellen schläge zeigen
deutlich wie around die seewa aber es
gibt keinen hinweis darauf dass das
lemming allein das schiff beschädigt hat
obwohl es zu einem starken stampfen kam
und man die erschütterungen im ganzen
schiff spüren konnte schien es doch als
ob es ziemlich sicher war diese richtung
führt uns also in eine sackgasse
die ermittler vermuten dass die
unglücksursache im rumpf selbst liegen
könnte
[Musik]
das schiff würde ich mir echt gern mal
anschauen aber
die bergung der napoli ist ins stocken
geraten
nach einer zweitägigen schleppaktion ist
schluss 60 kilometer vor dem ziel
um 70 26 rief uns das
bergungsunternehmen an und sagte die
risse werden größer sie läuft voll
wasser und singt
und zwar ziemlich schnell im ärmelkanal
droht eine umweltkatastrophe
die suche nach den unglücksursachen muss
erstmal warten wie napoli ist in
schwierigkeiten
robin middleton ist wieder im zugzwang
er hat gerade erfahren dass das
havarierte schiff es nicht mehr bis
portland schaffen werden ihr untergang
würde vermutlich eine ölpest auslösen
die so weit draußen auf dem meer nur
schwer eingedämmt werden könnte das
schiff muss an die küste
wir müssen nach brands kommen
dort wollen sie es kontrolliert auf
grundsätzen
nach einem unfall kann man die uhr nicht
einfach zurück trainer man muss seinen
plan für das worst case szenario
entwickeln und das habe ich getan
mittels zinsentscheidung ist heikel
branson liegt in der laimburg ganz in
der nähe aber die gegend gehört zum
weltnaturerbe der unesco rom nicht der
beste ort um ein schiff mit tausenden
tonnen schweröl an bord aufgrund zu
setzen
[Musik]
am 20 januar 2007 zwei tage nach der
havarie wird die napoli auf grund
gesetzt rund einen kilometer von der
küste entfernt
[Musik]
es war eine schwierige entscheidung
wer nicht liest das schiff in einem
geschützten und empfindlichsten regionen
großbritanniens stranden
retiro arbeitet als freiwilliger bei der
küstenwache er soll sich die lage
anschauen
ich hatte noch nie etwas so großes so
nah an der küste gesehen in dieser
position
das war ganz schön
auslaufendes öl treibt meist an der
oberfläche
die bergungsteams ziehen schnell einen
ring aus schwimmenden barrieren um das
schiff sie sollen verhindern dass der
ölteppich die küste oder das offene meer
erreicht
ohne richtigen schutz kann ein vorfall
wie bei der napoli schnell ausarten aus
einem schiffsunglück wird dann eine
umweltkatastrophe
der ölteppich konnte von der
meeresoberfläche abgesaugt und in
containern entsorgt werden die arbeiten
waren ziemlich effektiv
ein paar strände werden dennoch
verschmutzt aber die gefürchtete lässt
bleibt aus
doch es gibt eine weitere gefahr die
napoli bekommt immer mehr schlagseite
mehr als 100 container gehen über bord
[Musik]
einige sinken aber ein paar weitere
treiben in einer der meistbefahrenen
wasserstraßen der welt
[Musik]
sie waren entweder knapp über der
wasseroberfläche oder knapp darunter
hatte damals das kommando in der
zuständigen station der küstenwache
so ein gut zwölf meter langer
vollbeladener stahlcontainer ist eine
echte gefahr auf einer wasserstraße
das wichtigste für uns war zu berechnen
wohin sie treiben würden und dann die
schiffe auf diesem abschnitt des
ärmelkanals zu warnen
fast 60 container werden am strand von
brands kam angespült das ruft im nu
plünderer auf den plan auch die medien
stürzen sich auf die story
wir waren total überrumpelt wie schnell
so viele leute da war
die leute kamen von überall her an den
strand ein ganzes heer von gaffern die
gucken wollten was da los ist
die standorte brechen die container auf
und schleppen alles weg was sie kriegen
können
da gab es leute die mit bmw lenkrädern
vom strand kamen
ich glaube für so ein fast konnte man
zehn pfund bekommen
es gab auch einen behälter mit windeln
der aufgegangen war soweit ich weiß
haben sich windeln voll mit wasser und
diese da hatten im ärmelkanal gelegen
ich habe keine ahnung was die leute
damit wollten
nach britischem recht muss gefundenen
strandgut dem rechtmäßigen besitzer
zurückgegeben werden wenn diese
ansprüche erhebt aber dieses recht ist
hier nicht so einfach durchzusetzen
wir wurden mit formularen an die strecke
geschickt die leute sollten sie
ausfüllen und an die zuständigen
behörden zurückschicken aber ich weiß
noch wie ich das formular einem gewissen
gentleman aushändigte
meinen augen und sagte nur weiter machen
robin middletons notfallplan hat eine
umweltkatastrophe verhindert aber was
die öffentliche ordnung angeht herrscht
teilweise chaos
ich glaube jeder der mit dem einsatz zu
tun hatte dachte dass mich das den job
kosten wird
das war wirklich eine große geschichte
so einen riesigen frachter hat man nicht
oft im britischen küstengewässern es war
ein fesselnder anblick für alle
ein positiver nebeneffekt die plünderung
regen aufmerksamkeit das beschleunigt
die ermittlungen
es war ein schwerer unfall und die leute
wollten wissen wie man damit umgeht wir
mussten also schnell in die pötte kommen
und wir brauchten ergebnisse jetzt da
die napoli vor der südküste englands auf
grund liegt können die
bergungsspezialisten aus frankreich und
den niederlanden das schiff sichern und
die ermittler dürfen endlich das fragt
betreten wir konnten es kaum erwarten an
bord zu gehen und die nötigen beweise zu
sammeln
passt auf wo ihr hin tretet
aber wir mussten uns genau mit den
bergungsspezialisten absprechen und
verhandeln wann es sicher genug für uns
war an bord zu gehen
aus den tanks oder den maschinen war öl
ausgelaufen und das klebte überall es
war super rutschig und das schiff lag so
komisch auf der seite
es war sehr seltsam da reinzugehen
sie suchen nach jedem noch so kleinen
hinweis auf die mögliche unglücksursache
das sammeln von beweisen ist das
wichtigste
alles wird genau dokumentiert
der computer mit den fachdaten könnte
aufschluss bringen die mussten
herausfinden welche ladung an bord war
was sie wo und wie sie verteilt war
das hier stimmt nicht
über den computer können sie die ladung
die in den frachtpapieren steht mit der
tatsächlichen ladung vergleichen
und das hier über ladenden container die
auch noch falsch verteilt sind können
die stabilität eines schiffes gefährden
die frachtdaten sind beunruhigend
mindestens 20 prozent der fast 700
container entdeckt hatten ein
übergewicht von drei tonnen oder mehr
und mehr als 50 container standen an der
falschen stelle
wenn man nicht weiß wie viel ein
container wiegt ist es sehr schwer ein
schiff sicher zu beladen da kann man
sich keinen fehler erlauben
die ermittler rechnen aus dass durch das
übergewicht fast 99 prozent der
maximalen ladekapazität der napoli
erreicht war
knapp an der grenze der sicherheits
spielraum war fast komplett ausgereizt
aber der eigentliche caro schlag muss
durch etwas anderes gekommen sein
was war da los was war der tropfen der
das fass zum überlaufen gebracht hat
der mit real knöpfen sich die
vorgeschichte der napoli vor und werden
fündig
das hier war nicht ihre erste wahl
vor sechs jahren ist sie mit voller
kraft auf grund gelaufen mit voller
kraft
im april 2001 strandete das schiff in
der straße von malakka
damals heißt der frachter noch normandie
das brachte uns ganz schön ins grübeln
war bei dem unfall damals vielleicht die
trägerstruktur des schiffes beschädigt
worden
aber die theorie hält auf den zweiten
blick nicht stand
der schaden damals war am vorderen
buchende unmöglich dass das sie am heck
solche auswirkungen gehabt hätte
die ermittlung stecken in einer
sackgasse ein blick auf den riss am heck
könnte weiterhelfen
aber die untersuchung muss unter wasser
stattfinden
taucha wir haben heuer signal tat bitte
fort
fotoaufnahmen der bruchstelle könnten
aufschluss bringen warum der stahl
nachgegeben hat
wir waren mittlerweile ziemlich
ungeduldig und wollten unbedingt mehr
informationen bekommen alle hofften
durch die taucher und den tauchroboter
einen genaueren blick auf den schaden
werfen zu können
ein ermittler muss methodisch vorgehen
geduld haben und sich jede information
genau anschauen er darf nicht einfach
aufgeben
taucher ein bisschen mehr nach links
bitte
aber der frust nimmt kein ende
ich sehe gar nichts
wir haben den ganzen tag verzweifelt
versucht irgendwie bilder vom rumpf zu
machen aber durch den ganzen
aufgewirbelten sand und die trümmer war
die sicht eine einzige katastrophe
das bringt nichts
ja leider
auch das urteil der bergungsteams ist
ernüchternd dinapoli kann nicht wieder
flott gemacht werden das schiff muss vor
der küste zerlegt werden zuerst so dass
wasser aus dem rumpf gepumpt
dann wird das frag kontrolliert
gesprengt
bug und heck teil des schiffes mussten
voneinander getrennt werden
in zwei hälften lässt sich das rad
leichter abtransportieren
das heck wird vor ort zerlegt der bug
wird in eine werft nach belfast gebracht
[Musik]
für burg wurde in einer recyclinganlage
bei harland and hof wieder verwertet
gleich nebenan bei einst die titanic
gebaut worden
die msc napoli ist geschichte aber warum
sie verunglückt ist bleibt weiter ein
geheimnis
die ermittler kommen zu einem
beunruhigenden schluss
was muss am design legen
vielleicht gab es einen versteckten
konstruktionsfehler der erst deutlich
wurde als eine bestimmte reihe von
faktoren zusammen kamen die ermittler
müssen jedes detail unter die lupe
nehmen
wir besorgten uns eine kopie der
konstruktionszeichnungen um
nachzuschauen ob es irgendwelche
schwachstellen bei der nato
der riss ist hier
unter der maschinenraum
genau da wo sich die rahmen struktur
ändert
der rumpf der napoli ist durch
stahlträger verstärkt aber unter dem
maschinenraum zeigen sie ab um das
gewicht der motoren besser zu verteilen
und genau an dieser stelle nimmt das
unglück seinen lauf
verdammt wassereinbruch im maschinenraum
sofort runter und nachschauen was los
ist wir sagen dass es am maschinenraum
tatsächlich eine schwachstelle in der
trägerstruktur gab
dieser bereich war womöglich schwächer
als der rest
die ermittler glauben dass sie endlich
auf der richtigen spur sind aber die
napoli ist als modernes schiff unter
strengen auflagen gebaut worden
wie konnte den ingenieuren so ein fehler
durchrutschen
windgeschwindigkeit 60 knoten und wie
viele schiffe sind noch eingefahren
bei der suche nach der ursache für die
havarie
konzentrieren sich die ermittler nun
ganz auf die mögliche schwachstelle im
um
das design war nicht ungewöhnlich aber
der maschinenraum war bei diesem entwurf
ziemlich weit nach vorn gerutscht
der maschinenraum liegt bei der napoli
mehr in der mitte des schiffes ein
bereich der ostsee besonders starken
belastungen ausgesetzt ist der rahmen
unter dem maschinenraum lag in einem
stark belasteten teil des rumpfes
war das der schwachpunkt der napoli eine
spannende und gewagte theorie
langsam bekamen wir ein bild davon was
diesen unfall ausgelöst haben könnte
aber wir mussten das noch gründlicher
prüfen dazu tragen die ermittler alle
gefundenen spuren zusammen sie wollen
den moment in dem das schiff leck
geschlagen ist möglichst genau
rekonstruieren
vielleicht klärt dass die frage warum
hat das schiff den belastungen an diesem
tag nicht standgehalten
riesen probleme im maschinenraum ist
wasser sieht aus wie ein leck am rumpf
die britischen ermittler überprüfen die
theorie gemeinsam mit gutachtern der
klassifikationsgesellschaft dnv seegang
neun meter das internationale
unternehmen hilft bei der entwicklung
von standards für den schiffsbau
windgeschwindigkeit 60 knoten mit hilfe
der gesammelten daten erstellen sie eine
computersimulation
alles wird berücksichtigt der sturm das
übergewicht der ladung die kraft der
wellen
simulation starb wie wird sich der
modell rumpf erhalten
[Musik]
frachtschiffe sind eigentlich so
konstruiert dass es immer noch einen
sicherheitspuffer zu den kräften gibt
den sie voraussichtlich ausgesetzt sind
er war bei einem sturm oder wenn sie
über lagen sind
das ergebnis der simulation zeigt es
deutlich mit einer kleinen rest
unsicherheit können die ermittler nun
sagen dass die summe aller faktoren an
diesem tag der napoli den rest gab
in diesem moment waren die äußeren
kräfte größer als das schiff aushalten
konnte vom design her war wohl ein
sicherheitsspiel raum vorbehalten aber
wenn dann noch etwas hinzu kommt ist das
system an seinen grenzen hier waren es
die überladenen container der seegang
alles zusammen
vor allem ein stressfaktor war wohl am
ende zu viel der heftige schlag als das
stampfende frontal auf die wellen traf
als das zu allem überfluss noch dazu kam
war es vermutlich der berühmte letzte
tropfen der
abschlussbericht der britischen
untersuchungsbehörde hat folgen
1500 containerschiffe werden überprüft
12 weisen ähnliche schwachstellen wie
die msc napoli auf sie werden sofort auf
die werften geschickt
ich denke diese ermittlungen helfen
leben zu retten denn es wurden nicht nur
sofort ähnliche schiffe unter die lupe
genommen auch das design zukünftiger
schiffe wurde verändert
alle neuen container schiffe müssen
künftig mit einem stärkeren rumpf gebaut
werden
wegen unsere untersuchungsergebnisse
müssen bei der konstruktion größerer
schiffe heute weitreichendere
belastungstests durchgeführt werden
und um überladung zu verhindern dürfen
containerschiffen uhr auslaufen wenn ihr
brutto gesamtgewicht bestätigt wurde
[Musik]
die industrie versucht immer an alles zu
denken
aber erst wenn es zu solchen vorfällen
kommt merkt man wo tatsächlich noch
schwachstellen sind
[Musik]
die neuen regeln werden nicht nur
schiffe retten
sondern auch leben
für die ermittler ist das eine
genugtuung dass sich ihre hartnäckige
und akribische arbeit so sehr gelohnt
hat
die erfahrung zeigt dass man geduld
haben muss und nicht locker lassen darf
wenn ein weg dich nicht weiterführt
profi einen anderen irgendwo tut sich
immer was auf
wir müssen
robin middleton wurde für seine
entscheidung die napoli vor brems können
aufgrund zu setzen heftig angefeindet
aber der pensionierte behördenchef
glaubt dass seine kritiker etwas
wichtiges übersehen
am ende zählt das ergebnis
die entscheidungen haben sich
rückblickend als richtig herausgestellt
damals hielten viele leute das alles für
falsch aber tatsächlich ist aus dem
napoli schiffsunglück eben keine
umweltkatastrophe geworden
ich denke er war genau die richtige
person zum richtigen zeitpunkt robin
hatte die gabe die unterschiedlichsten
leute zu einem team zu vereinen und sie
dazu zu bringen sich ganz auf das
gemeinsame ziel zu konzentrieren
[Musik]
pop star fährt immer noch zur see die
erinnerung dass napoli unglück hat ihn
geprägt
wenn man das erste mal am dock steht und
so ein starkes großes schiff sieht denkt
man mit so etwas kann man doch keinen
schiffbruch erleiden das ding hält alles
aus aber dann kommt doch der fall der
fälle man muss immer auf alles
vorbereitet sein
ich werde das nie vergessen
und das macht mich stärker